there are many factors that drive
businesses forward
but at the heart of a successful company
are teams with an agile mindset
now more than ever organizations have
adopted the transformative power of
agile
83 of companies rely on teams using
agile frameworks to build amazing
products that consumers will love
with udacity's agile software
development nanodegree program
you will learn how to manage software
development and delivery like the pros
our instructors will use their decades
of experience to teach you how to
problem solve
prioritize and deliver while managing an
agile workflow for any team
working from anywhere at the end of this
nanodegree program
you will be able to lead a high
performing team that can deliver on
business
objectives your new skills will enable
you to communicate cross-functionally
remove roadblocks and boost your team's
value to the company
get hands-on experience with projects
focused on real-world challenges
you will plan a minimal viable product
release
write user stories and manage a backlog
lead sprint planning and report metrics
on progress and risks
build your agile software development
skill set and lead your team to success
enroll in udacity's agile software
development
nanodegree program today